and so here in game two it's going to be
mitch keller the right-hander for the
pirates two and six with a 741 era
rymel tapia who was one for four in game
one
it is a cool it's warmed up to 52 now
in the pitch strike three call froze him
on a high curve ball
and now cj crone a righty batter
281 hitter keller from the slide step
the o2 and a swing and a miss put him
away with a good down and away
sliders excellent location there right
where he wanted it so two outs
for charlie blackmon 2-1 for mitch
swinging a little liner and caught by
the leaping shortstop
pardon me third baseman gonzalez playing
short and the inning ends
a walk and a man left and we're through
a half inning it's the rockies nothing
and the pirates coming up
austin gomber came over in the arenato
deal from the cardinals in the off
season he's three and four
with a 456 earned run average
the whip is the walks and hits combined
frazier hits one to right and deep and
gone
his 10th career leadoff home run
and the pirates start off with a blast
one to nothing
either that's probably two-thirds of the
way up
this is kevin newman did not play
in the opener starting the nightcap at
shortstop
pitch is hit in the air to center field
dazzle coming on jonathan under
and grabs it one down the homer for
reynolds was his
sixth the pirates despite their
struggles have played the rockies tough
over the last few years
there's a comebacker handled easily by
gomber runs
halfway to first flips it underhand to
cj chrome for the second out
i mean you'll get big catchers but for
a tall guy stallings is slender
i mean if you saw him and somebody said
he's a catcher you'd go nah
i don't think so but he is breaking ball
tried to check his swing
did not and that's strike three
so a bounce back for gomber after the
lead-off homer
setting up alias diaz here's the former
pirate no stranger to this ballpark
elias diaz and he lines out the third to
end the inning
a hidden a man left through an inning
and a half will craig leading off for
the pirates
rocky's down one to nothing a leadoff
first pitch adam frazier home run
off gomber craig a wake forest product
gamal and gonzalez also scheduled to hit
here in the pittsburgh
second 0-2 pitch swing and a miss
got him on the changeup second strikeout
for austin gomberg here's austin gomber
pirates leading on the fraser home run
now the o2 strike three call got him on
a fastball one out
third strikeout for keller
first and second one out pirates batting
in the third leading one nothing
and brian reynolds here's a 3-2 runners
go and the pitch is ball four
it sails into the left field and the
runners can advance at their own peril
there will be no peril
it's a throwing error in a run for the
bucks it's two to nothing
that ball wasn't any more close
elias diaz just unloaded that ball
and he's going to be assessed in error
to just gift wrapper run
stalling struck out his first time
gomber with the count at one and two
fastball called strike three and
stallings turns and heads back to the
dugout
rocky's gonna need to rally a bit in
order to salvage a split two-nothing
pirates lead in the third runners at
first and second for
pittsburgh with will craig at the plate
coming down the line from third is
newman
there's the pitch and it's a called
strike three
austin gomber sends will craig back to
the dugout and limits the damage
to one run krone one of the three
strikeouts
for mitch keller pirates aiming for a
doubleheader sweep today they won seven
nothing in game one
up two nothing here three two again
swing and a miss struck him out with
that down and away slider
keller with his fourth strikeout today
here's brendan rodgers
i had one two here it is right there
strike three call
locked him up with a fastball keller has
sent down seven in a row
and we'll go on to the fifth two ounces
at the bottom of the fourth of this
seven inning game i tom off the injured
list today
here's tom on his birthday sends one
deep out to right
center happy birthday tom
a line drive home run for kai tom
three nothing buckos and that was a
bullet out of here that didn't have
hardly any height at all
aloha welcome back
and it's three nothing his second home
run that was a shot
he hit that 109 411
feet here's keller the pitcher owen two
right back to the plate breaking ball
called strike three
and the pirates will get the one run in
the fourth
joshua fuentes is now in
wow a pitcher looks more confident when
they're successful
but the way that he's pitching with the
fastball like you said the last two
hitters in here to this one
that's a confident kind of pitcher look
going after him
for the rockies and now second and third
with two outs for
tapia two and two with two on and two
out of the pitch
swinging a soft ground ball with some
english on it on to short newman has it
on to first
and craig scooped it out he got him in
and ends the inning
mitch keller gets out of that second and
third jam
and he's pitched five scoreless innings
three-nothing pirates craig is punched
out twice
0-2 and a swing and a fly ball softly
hit to right
falling fast blackman can't get their
base hit here comes stallings the throws
cut off
rbi single for craig bucks up four to
nothing
blackman did a nice job you see his
veteran
you know all the games he's played in
the outfield he threw the glove up like
he was
calling for it like he was going to
catch it what he's trying to do
is keep stallings next to the back all
right it's up to tapia here
to center field and raise the jolly
roger
twice on a saturday
the pirates shut out the rockies
both games seven nothing in game one
and four nothing in game two